uh also hi to our online participants
it's a pleasure to
introduce nika who's a professor here
who's going to
tell us about learning and incentives
and how they interact thank you nika
thank you
thanks for being here
i'm really glad that i'm here and i can
see you guys in person and i hope to get
to see the people who are online at some
point this semester or near future as
well
so um
yeah so the title of this talk is
learning and incentives
and but i was thinking about so what am
i going to talk about learning and
incentives i've had tutorials about this
topic but it's so broad
i thought maybe a better title for this
specific talk i'm going to give today on
tomorrow would be learning with
strategic interactions i mean they're
very related but at least this allows me
to tell you about specific types of
strategic interactions that we're going
to be dealing with today and tomorrow so
that we can both remain grounded but
also think about the applications of
where these interactions actually come
into play
and we're going to develop a principle
way of talking about these interactions
using tools from theory of machine
learning and algorithmic economics
so
learning and learnability if i go
decades back the question of what can be
learned from data and limited
observations has been something that
really started the foundations of theory
of machine learning as a whole field
we've been wondering for decades what
can we learn from data
and even how do we even talk about
learnability
the usual goal is that we have some
process that's spitting out some data we
have some limited observations of this
and then we want to use these limited
observations to learn some concepts some
facts
these concepts and facts are really
abstract
anterior machine learning will tell us
what facts and concepts can be learned
from observations
so this is where learning and
learnability comes from if i go back to
the seminal work of valiant
who was
really talking about foundations of
learning you know what can be learned
what types of concepts and facts can be
learned from
theta i was intrigued to find that the
example that was given in that paper
was of familiar objects images of
familiar objects such as tables chairs i
can add other examples
today we usually hear about cats and
dogs and cars and ships
and i think it's actually really
important to
think about why such an example was
chosen
if we go back
the most basic setting of machine
learning
and especially theoretical models for
machine learning
really involves these distributions that
are about something stationary that's
happening in the world and you get to
get some observations from it
the world does not respond to you the
decisions you make as to whether or not
an image includes a cat or a dog or a
table or a chair has no bearing on that
table or chair they're not going to be
offended they're not going to change
their appearance they're not going to
leave your data set because you didn't
recognize them
and that's not what we are seeing today
in the applications of learning
today we have all of these interactions
that i was talking about
because our learning algorithms are
being applied for decision making not
just for recognizing patterns that may
be in some images especially patterns of
objects
but about actually using the
observations to make decisions and these
decisions are going to impact people or
other entities who are involved
so what are examples of this even if i
talk about image recognition but now i'm
talking about human faces this is a
completely different story people are
going to be affected by this
if i talk about image recognition and i
talk about whether or not my macbook is
going to let me access my computer by
just recognizing my
face
that's one that again there's an
interaction i can put on glasses take it
off put on a mask i can try to change
that
there are many other applications
address i've
tried to put a couple of these here
and the examples i chose here were to
highlight three different types of
interactions that we're going to see
today
i'm going to be talking about strategic
generally speaking
and specifically speaking some
adversarial interactions
i'm then going to be talking about
collaborative interactions which is
really going to be tomorrow
but something to note about all of these
is that um
they
type of strategic manipulation that can
really mess with our learning algorithms
and we're going to see this
so when we talk
actually so let me just talk about some
of the examples here
so an example of ride sharing uber lyft
you know
you as a driver have a lot of
flexibility to strategically manipulate
your availability the location of your
car
whether or not you're going to accept
the ride and all of these there's ample
evidence that people actually do these
to change the price and the right that
they're going to get immediately after
because they know our algorithms are
going to respond our matching algorithms
are going to respond to how they're
going to be matched with um writers
similarly content moderation like
youtube
uh
the algorithms that are trying to catch
um illegal uh data on youtube
uh they need to be constantly updated
because as soon as some things about the
patterns that they are recognizing
gets noticed by people who want to
actually post illegal illegal content
they're going to change their legal
content maybe add you know
like some red buffs around it just
changes so that our algorithms are not
going to be catching them
so those are examples of the youtube
content is an example of an adversarial
interaction
the uber and lyft is an example of
broadly speaking strategic interaction
strategic interactions that are not
necessarily malicious or adversarial but
opportunistic
are in many different places so
some other examples are
what you see for example in admission
lending hiring search
uh you're trying to
perhaps improve your chances of getting
through a screening to get interviewed
then for your favorite job you will go
and decide how you're going to actually
represent your experiences on your cv
or you might actually take specific
courses or tutorials or certificates so
that not only hopefully you're actually
improving your qualifications but also
you're sending a better signal about
your qualifications so these are broadly
speaking strategic interactions that
could be beneficial but there are things
that we definitely need to actually
account for because if we don't account
for them or if we think that they are
just malicious
we are losing an opportunity to actually
make changes
and the last part is going to be about
collaborative interactions
what's probably the hardest to actually
show in this slide
there's an emerging market for data and
sharing of data
this is happening because a lot of the
times data is
held by strategic stakeholders
let's say banks hospitals medical center
medical centers who have parts of data
they want to learn concepts or facts
that are related more broadly like banks
want to figure out if something is
happening if there is a fraud going on
and having access to other banks data is
something that's going to really help
them
similarly with medical centers or
hospitals
the
a lot of genomic studies they require so
much data that's not found in one
location
but we want to actually enable people
enable these centers to work on data
and find
important scientific findings that's
going to help everyone but still
keep their
data either
safe private or also make sure that the
ownership of data is uh left with them
um so there are all these questions that
you're going to be really thinking about
today on tomorrow
as i said there are three categories
that we're going to be focusing on uh
adversarial which comes first then i'll
talk about strategic and then i'll talk
about collaborative
and i've highlighted four questions that
are we are going to broadly ask they
sort of are scattered around the four
parts of the tutorial
but i thought it's nevertheless helpful
to just highlight them
uh even though they might not have to a
specific part of the tutorial
so as i said we're going to really start
understanding
the learnability part
we're going to talk about the question
of what concepts can be learned from
data and presence of strategic behavior
and for that we're going to talk about
adversarial and strategic behavior and
also try to understand how lessons that
we've learned from decades of work in
this area is going to address our needs
for today
and especially today's world and today's
applications
that part is mostly statistical but
there's also an algorithmic aspect to
this which is how do you design
algorithms for strategic and adversarial
environments
of course there are questions about
computational tractability that i will
talk about very briefly only
but there are also questions about what
are general principles about how to use
and how not to use data when i know that
there are these feedback loops in
practice
we'll also talk about uh how to design
collaborative environments to design to
encourage learner participation
so here we want to incentivize
learning algorithms to participate in
data sharing data sharing protocols
and we want to at the same time deliver
solutions that are optimal both for
individual learners and also for sort of
society as a whole so that uh
um sort of
every stakeholder and society are going
to benefit from this
and at a very high level
and the three parts of the tutorial that
the adversarial strategic and
collaborative learning there are
mathematical tools that are connecting
them most of these mathematical tools
i'm going to actually introduce
them to you pretty early on but i will
highlight them again how do these
learning paradigms sort of connect to
one another as we continue with the
tutorial
so that's the plan
um my hope is that
today
we'll talk about adversarial
interactions
and we'll start talking about uh general
strategic interactions that go beyond
adversarial interactions
uh i might be uh this might be wishful
thinking so we'll see if we can hit the
very first one here i'll be very happy
but i don't want to rush us so we can
sort of
choose our own adventure and figure out
what are the parts that we want to spend
more time
so
um
and then tomorrow i'm going to work talk
a lot more about sort of general
strategic interactions
and then collaborative interactions this
is wednesday thursday
yes i guess i'm a day behind sorry
yeah
well
any questions i know i didn't tell you
anything substantive enough to ask
questions but if you have questions
nevertheless go ahead
okay
so
here's the plan for the first part the
adversarial interactions part
i'm going to be talking about five small
parts here
and let me apologize to those of you who
are experts in learning theory we're
going to go through some basic concepts
because i want everyone to be on the
same page
um
if
but i still promise you
that by the time we hit uh
these two parts i'm already going to
give you results
from the past 12 months so there's
something to look forward to even if you
know a lot of these topics
okay so we'll start with sort of the
most basic
bread and butter kind of learning theory
and that is what's sometimes referred to
as offline learning agnostic learning i
like to call it stochastic for the
purpose of this tutorial
but sort of what you want to think about
in this setting is that
the type of usage example you want to
have in mind
is the the example of the table i was
giving you is when you want to learn to
detect some natural phenomena or some
objects trees animals things that
essentially are not going to react to
whatever you do
so you could assume very easily that
there are distributions of these items
that you're trying to understand
and the idea here is that in this world
data is assumed to be generated
stochastically from an unknown but
nevertheless fixed distribution
and then the goal of the learner is to
learn a function
from this data and we say that the
learner was successful if it can achieve
good performance for measured on the
same underlying distribution so this is
not concerned with robustness it's not
concerned with strategicness it's just
about
seeing data from some distribution
now the formal setup of this
in the stochastic setting is that
we have uh we have t interactions
between a learner and a world and at
each time step this world is going to
generate
instances xt yt from this distribution
for the sake of simplicity we can assume
that xc are images
yt is yes or no so does this image have
a tree in it
and then the learner has to pick a
prediction rule this prediction rule is
shown by f of t
and while the learner is given access to
a base class class age it doesn't
actually have to pick anything from that
class necessarily this just has to come
up with some prediction rule
and the learner gets to observe after
every round what was the instance and
how well they did and if it made a
mistake it's bad it doesn't want to make
mistakes
so the way we measure the success of
this algorithm is something that we're
going to call average regret if i call
it regret it's the same thing
and this is the average number of
mistakes the algorithm is making over t
time steps versus
the
average number of mistakes the best
fixed
classifier in our base set of h would
have made
and the idea is that
you can learn
if you get vanishing average regret as t
goes to infinity
as t goes to infinity if this is zero
essentially what you're saying is that
on average the algorithm did as best as
it could have done in hindsight
so this is a very basic
model of stochastic
learning
now notice that
the really important part of this model
in fact i've chosen a model that's
slightly weird
but an unusual perhaps
it's really about the emphasis on this
world's generating data iid
in fact
a more common way of viewing this um in
a slightly different model but for our
purposes is essentially the same
is the offline learning model that many
of you are familiar with and the offline
learning model to really emphasize on
the fact that there is no interaction
i'm just going to remove the fact that
the algorithm has to make predictions
successively at every round and just say
that actually the world creates a sample
set the sample set is created iid from a
distribution again emphasis on iid
and after the learner observes
everything in the sample set it has to
come up with that prediction rule
i would still measure the success of
this algorithm using something that is
essentially the average regret
here
another way to say that is that the
average regret is
the
the this is the performance of my
predictor
on the data
not just on the observations i received
but actually on the underlying
distribution
and then i'm trying to compete with the
best hypothesis best classifier measured
again on that unknown distribution
and i want this to be again something
that goes to zero as i increase t
usually we think about these as sample
complexity bounds in the sense that i
say well if i want to get epsilon here
how many samples do i need to see
something like 1 over epsilon squared
times some
something that we are going to see
or i could talk about the average regret
in terms of
the dependence of it on the number of
observations i've had which is t
so
i just introduced you two models for
incentive purposes they are the same
although i will address the fact that
they're not actually but
just assume that they're the same
they're questions that's an h right
this is an h yes
yeah sorry there's a mistake here this
should have been
h
any other questions
okay
so
let me ask you as uh just i want to get
a sense of how much people have already
seen
if i give you this type of setting um do
you know what characterizes his
learnability those of you who have seen
this
could you please raise your hands
okay
good so
about half people this is half of the
people this is still some there's some
freshness to it so i'm happy
okay so
we're going to start with our very basic
question of what is going to
characterize
what i have not called offline
vulnerability
well the thing that characterizes this
is a notion of complexity of your class
of hypothesis that h
and it's called vc dimension
so what is vc dimension
pictorially for me the easiest perhaps
way to do this is
to put
into a matrix associate the rows with
hypothesis that the learner has access
to those are the base class hypothesis
on the columns i put all the instances
in my domain
and then these are the predictions that
it's making so
h is the h2 is saying x2 is minus 1.
and then i look at this table and i say
well the vc dimension of this hypothesis
class
is
the largest d
where there's a sub matrix of d columns
where if i only look at those d columns
i'm actually seeing every way of
labeling those d columns which is two to
the d different rows okay
so each row is a different way of
labeling basically the different
instances
and vc dimension put another way is the
largest sample set
that you can label every possible way
and that's pc dimension
the nice thing about bc dimension is
that it's a simple combinatorial object
and it actually characterizes what is
learnable
in the worst case that is
so for any class of hypothesis h
the optimal sample complexity
optimal when i think about sort of the
worst case optimal over all possible
unknown distributions
is the one that says it's oops sorry
it's about um there's a tilde some
logarithmic terms
it's about
vc dimension of that class over
excellent squared
or i could have thought about the
average regret also i needed theta tilde
theta here is about vc dimension over t
so this
here
vc dimension is appearing both as upper
and lower bound
for telling us how much data we need or
what regret we can expect in the worst
case
any questions about this
let me
give you an example of vc dimension it's
a very simple example but i think it's
nevertheless interesting
so the simplest example of vc dimension
is typically thresholds on a line
so what i'm thinking about is that my
hypothesis class is just these
thresholds that they're essentially zero
zero zero and then they switch to one
one one one
and such a class i ask what is this vc
dimension
it's not hard to see that it's just one
because
well it's very easy that i can get just
a single point and i can label it two
different ways by just having two
different thresholds
but no matter what two points i pick
there's no way that i can produce a plus
on the smaller one and minus on the
larger one
so this here the fact that vc dimension
is one
is telling us that if i had a
distribution i can learn this concept
class really easily
because it's just the the dimensionality
of it is essentially one
okay so
now that we have seen an example of bc
dimension
at a high level why vc dimension is the
right thing here and i'm not going to
give you a proof of this
you can pick your
favorite learning theory book and read
it
but i will tell you a high level of why
this is expected
so
you should have expected vc dimension to
play a role as a lower bound on the
number of samples you need it let's talk
about samples i think it's a little bit
easier
why
let's say that i only observed d minus
one number of samples
and uh
because i only observed this
and now i'm given a new point
this new point
i have no idea like any hypothesis that
i can i have fixed is labels
still half of them can say plus one year
half of them can say minus one like
i could have explained this as a plus or
minus regardless
so in some sense the minimum number of
things i need to see before i can
actually generalize from data
is the number of things that i can fully
explain no matter what because once i
have seen this now i'm creating some
bias where it's actually hypothesis that
sort of match these
so this is the underlying reason as to
why vc dimension plays a lower bound
role in sample complexity
the more interesting part is why does it
play an upper bound
and
there
sort of another way to think about this
is that
if i had a finite
class of hypothesis i was trying to work
with
then i could use very elementary
probability statistics and use
concentration bounds and union bounds
and get something that looks like this
what is this saying
it's essentially saying that forget
about that there is finite d many h just
say that there was a single hypothesis
it's just that i'm seeing a coin
and i know that i want to know what is
the bias of this coin is it half is it
0.7 what is it
so to understand that single coin i
would have needed these many samples
this is just something like a gaussian
tail
now that i have many different
hypotheses for each of them i want to
measure this
and union bound is going to tell me that
my estimation the probability of sort of
making a bad judgment is going to blow
up by h
so that's for a finite class
what visa dimension essentially does is
that it says that
actually
it's not just about finite classes but
i can try to talk about how many
labelings i can produce on my sample set
by itself or something that looks like
my sample set
and if that size is very small then i
can replace this with essentially that
effective size of those labeling the
effective number of those labelings
rather than looking over all my
hypothesis class
and it turns out that vc dimension is
exactly what is going to capture the
effective sides of the hypothesis class
because it's talking about the power of
a hypothesis class producing all
possible labelings on a sample set
so this is at a high level why bc
dimension works here
okay um
are there any questions about this
we're going to build upon this
we're going to make this a little bit
more interesting
okay
so
next i'm going to
work my way towards something that's
referred to as online learning
and here the example of usage that you
want to have in mind is sort of
that adversarial behavior
so you could think about um you're
trying to control the content quality of
um
youtube
videos and you're facing these
adversarial manipulations
uh for future instances that are
essentially
uh going to react to what you have done
and you need to at the same time make
decisions you get a new video am i going
to accept this or am i going to reject
it right now so that's an example of
this
and it's also used in learning in games
we've seen this course as a tutorial
eva's tutorial as well you've seen a lot
of this before
the idea is that because the adverse
there's an adversary in the loop who is
reacting to you there is no distribution
anymore it's just that observations are
evolving in unpredictable and
adversarial ways
and we are successful
if
i look back at my data on that
adversarial generated data and i can
still say something positive i did on it
so this is very robust to any
adversarial now reactions
um as opposed to the previous model we
were working with
so
if i start with the stochastic setting
of the previous setup that i was talking
about
let me tell you how you can change it to
make it online
so the first thing is you remove the
distribution
the second thing is that you replace the
world with an adversary so now this
adversary is picking xt
and it's picking it knowing everything
so the history of the place so far what
algorithm you have it's quite powerful
but the measure of what we use to
actually measure success average regret
all of that they still remain exactly
the same so it's just that the world
change and we remain the same
so this is a model of online learning
it's referred to as full information i'm
not going to use these keywords much
today
but for those of you who are familiar
with it what that means is that the
algorithm actually sees the instance uh
after each prediction so
it it could
compute these hypotheticals like oh but
if instead of the current classifier i
use this other classifier
so it can sort of know how well every
other classifier would have done as well
can i ask questions
in the youtube saying the ground truth
keeps changing right
so ground flow keeps changing in terms
of what so the things that used to be
pornography in the past might not be
drawn through the future ah so that's a
good question
you're assuming it's always the same
i'm assuming that ground truth is
defined in the future so
it is the part of the bottle yeah so if
you look here
this min age is saying that i'm trying
so in fact i'm not even define i'm not
committing to a ground fruit
the ground fruit is defined as the best
thing that in few years i would have
looked back so it's the label it's time
t
so you're trying to guess the label
i am trying to guess the label at time t
but so so let's look at this so the
ground truth okay so i think there are
two different ways to serve i think
um
i thought you were talking about bench
so the benchmark is defined in the
future the ground truth y t's they don't
change and i think mainly for another
good example of that but i'm thinking
more like um maybe copyrights maybe
um children's like inappropriate for
children's type content like these are
things that
the instance itself doesn't
change their perfectness for children
but there are situations where
definitely there are situations that
they do change i think that's
interesting you know what
let me come back to strategic
interaction we should talk more about
that because there's a slightly
different concept of regret that talks
about
certain types of changes
i don't think it will exactly capture
what you have online but uh
nevertheless it comes
another way to think about this is that
at the end of the day i'm still
measuring what my algorithm did
versus what given the same the same way
that i labeled like the true labels i
generated
so that's the notion of this kind of
regret
yes
probably you referred to at the
beginning is the horizon well known from
the beginning
i got that from the question
so
the simple answer is
um
whatever you want you want it to be
known it can be known if you don't want
it to be known it's not
essentially um there are algorithms that
you can change any algorithm if you're
willing to play a little bit
um so that it works a bit on the horizon
i'm not going to talk about that
i agree
doubling tricks etcetera but
my question is if the horizon is known
for the adversary in order to
submit the yt
from the beginning
or not
so adversary can be adopted
okay so even if it knows the horizon it
doesn't mean that it has created the
sequence
and an activity is actually important
okay any other questions
so
let me give you an online exam
so the the way to think about this
speaking is you know we keep the
distribution fixed and that's relatively
sampling uh from this distribution or is
the distribution change
okay so there's two ways to think about
this i can always add a distribution but
in a very naive way by saying that an
adversary at every round takes a new
distribution having known the whole
history but that distribution i'm
allowing it to be focused exactly on one
point so that picking
it doesn't matter that it's a
distribution
we'll come back to this in the second
half of the talk today
but another way is just like give
full flexibility to the adversary it's a
very powerful adversary there is no
distribution and every round it looks
back exactly it has kept track of the
algorithm what is it done and it says
today this is the instance i'm going to
produce okay so it has full
power of doing
picking any instance in the domain and
assigning it any y that it wants
do you mean it can generate any any pair
that he wants what does it mean in the
domain in this context
pick anything in the domain so
you have to usually commit to something
like a representation of the problem so
the domain x could be all images
or it could be all real valued uh like
anything in rs
that's the dom
it's just that it has to be to define
these settings we need to know what's a
domain because a predictor is a function
from the domain to labels so we kind of
need to
commit to that domain before we start
talking about predictors
okay
any other questions
just ask curiosity why is a little
uh
[Music]
good so
and a nice thing to think about this is
that i'm giving a lot of power to the
adversary okay so let me first say it
means two things
it could mean that the function itself
is random or it could mean that it
randomly picks a function okay let's
think about the randomly fixed function
so because i allow the adversary to
actually know the algorithm
plus the history the adversary can
actually compute the algorithm instead
so if the algorithm were to be
deterministic the adversary would know
what the next thing that the learner
produces is and will generate something
that's bad for it
so kind of randomness here is actually a
really important power that the learner
has to be able to use
so that it remains unpredictable so that
even when the adversary sort of
plugs in the history to the algorithm it
doesn't know exactly like it there's no
deterministic way of abusing its power
other questions
so we have one from the online
audience so the question is are there
any applications of this model
i the adversarial the adversary chooses
the data
for the learning algorithm and and you
know uh yeah i mean
yeah so actually i will partially refer
you to the previous tutorials as well
unless you're one of the people who gave
a tutorial then in that case i do not um
so yes so first of all
um
there are a bunch of applications of
this
theoretical applications actually this
type of online learning and assuming an
adaptive adversary is an important thing
in game theory
um
some of the stuff that eva talked about
on
monday i guess
would have required you to have an
regret algorithm
that has regret guarantees against an
adaptive adversary so when we think
about this applications and game theory
in particular um sort of adaptivity is
an important aspect although we can do
better than even more space adversaries
um other places that this is very useful
um
this has been
so it's even right now
versions of this like uh
sort of this on maybe steroid like kind
of saying oh you cannot
have some observations um the world is
evolving even
less predictably that you saw it and
you're trying to compete with something
that's even harder to compete with these
are definitely sort of the basis of
reinforcement learning and a bunch of
other sort of
approaches for
tweaking algorithms in online ways so
that uh you're providing both like for
content quality for matching for a lot
of different things so
this is the high level answer to that
but i if if you're thinking about the
theory of it i actually do find the
game theory and sort of adaptivity of
adversary as a nice example to have in
mind where the environment is actually
is responding to you and you don't want
to know exactly how it's responding and
you're willing to assume that it's a
it's an adaptive adversary
okay
so so now that we know what this model
is what it's used uh used for
um
ah yes i was going to give you an online
learning example
and i'm going to use the same hypothesis
class that i showed you has a vc
dimensional one so it was really easy to
learn for an offline learner
and we're going to see that the such a
simple cause of hypothesis is actually
impossible to learn in an online setting
what does this look like so i still have
these thresholds on a line
the algorithm has to predict labels of
an adaptively and adversarially selected
point um
per step
so what the adversary will do
is to start with any point it's easy to
just say it starts with half
and then asks you to label it no matter
how you label it the adversary can tell
you that actually you were wrong and the
true label was this other label
and then it can continue it's a very
kind of an inductive structure
he'll ask you about a quarter again no
matter what you do it says that you are
wrong
whenever it wants to stop or even if it
doesn't stop you can continue this
process until the end of time
the adversary can still give one
guarantee for itself which is that the
adversary was consistent
he might have in his mind have had some
kind of a consistent threshold
that every he gave you actually matches
this
but
you oops but you were
but you actually did pretty poorly with
respect to this
and it's important to know that
um why did you do poorly because at
every step i made sure that you made a
mistake so you made two mistakes and the
best hypothesis would have made zero
mistakes
and it's important to realize that it's
not just this path that you went through
sir could have walked through any path
so any way that you would have made a
prediction there would have been a way
for the adversary to continue yes just a
small quantity
[Music]
before you
so i i gave you a model and immediately
i didn't follow it so that was a very
good catch
now say
why why would i talk is essentially the
same thing
another way we could think about it is
the adversary would have picked one of
these paths out at random
okay
and because i take it at random now it's
consistent the x and y's are fixed even
though you don't know it
and now you don't make a deterministic
mistake you still make a mistake with
probability
good
so
it's still nevertheless it's nice to
keep in mind this kind of is the x i
first give you an x and then i'll tell
you why
the moral of the story is that in either
of these models you're making either two
over two or t mistakes
and uh
and the perf there would have been a
perfect thing with no mistakes
so the average regret is a constant it's
not gonna go to zero and i'm in trouble
so
at the very least what this example
should have taught us is that
vc dimension is not the thing that's
going to characterize online
learnability
because i had something of bc dimension
1
and i could not learn it at
all so
here really the fact that finite music
dimension is not sufficient for online
inability
is that vc dimension is really focusing
on on a
labeling a set
whereas i was talking about trees
and to really be able to like talk about
how expressive
your hypothesis class is you need to
also talk about trees or all these
sequences
and here is where the definition of
little stone trees or
shattering trees come in
the way that they're defined is that i
just have a full binary tree
of some depth
the nodes of it especially the interior
nodes
are x's these are the instances that
you're supposed to label
and i refer to them actually by their
position here so
this is x plus because i'm saying that
going right as a plus and going left is
a minus um this is x plus plus because i
started from the root and i went pluses
twice
this is x minus plus because of that
and now i can refer to any path by these
y's this is the y of the empty set being
plus
the y of the next one being minus
okay
now this is a little some tree and for
every path that i defined this way
the x's are labeled as their
corresponding y so y that actually came
after them
on this path for the single h here
so every path has a consistent
h
and h is consistent the same in the
sense that every x on that path x empty
set and y empty set
follow the predictions of that that
hypothesis h the same x plus and y plus
followed that the same age for each path
that's a little sun tree
and now the depth that or the height of
the largest little sun tree
is what's known as the little stone
dimension
this is
this could be a little bit hard to grasp
so if you have any questions a good time
to
okay ask much more extra the first time
i saw this
okay do you have a question
it's more the feeling that you don't
have the correct question to ask
what i'm trying to understand is
the
director of the exercise yesterday
so this is about exactly trying to
understand optimization problems i mean
so you want to make the largest of these
trees because if you remember i was
talking about vc dimension as the
largest thing you can sort of label
every bit
so you want the largest tree that can
have this property
okay it's very easy to have a tree of
size one you can just take one and then
they do it with the right way
but as soon as you start branching there
are two to the z kind of paths that you
need to keep consistent
okay
i will give you an example of this just
because i know this is a little bit hard
to grasp
let's look at this tree this is a little
sun dimension a little some tree
if you look in
into the mirror just because the pluses
and minuses are exactly reversed
so this is the left is between minus
when the right is becoming plus one
because at the end of the day i always
no matter what path i took
i had this hypothesis that said hey this
guy was consistent with this
this guy was consistent with this and
this guy was consistent with whichever i
whichever direction i went
so this is an example of an infinite
rule of entry
now let me give you an example
where you cannot have an infinite loose
entry the other question about this
stuff
i think maybe one more example is going
to help
so just to be sure the node is the alpha
so
this is the x's
so remember the nodes of a tree have to
have instances those are the x's
the edges are the labels
the edges play two rows they're both the
labels for that point and they they
actually define a path
so the label that you're defining
and the path have to be sort of
consistent that's why
okay
let me give you one more actually i have
two more examples um
let me give you an example of a small
little stone dimension tree that you
cannot grow any further
so think about a class h um
this class has this property that is
like plus one on just d place d of the
instances it can choose any d
it has to be zero or negative one
everywhere else
now my claim is that the little sun
dimension of this tree this
this class the biggest tree you can make
biggest full binary tree you can make
has dimension d
why because once i start from the root
there is at most d things that i can d
times i can go plus one
if i ever repeat a point i'm already
unfortunately done because i cannot
label it positive ones or negative ones
so i cannot repeat
and if i'm not repeating there's at most
d
things that could be positive so i can
go to the right only b times
so that's one way of knowing that this
delusion dimension tree is going to be
at most the height d have a question
good if i discretize my previous example
do you want to tell me what would have
been the other
number
would have been the log of the size
that's right yeah so if i said that
actually i'm looking at only integers
from 0 to 2 to the d then i would have
been on just
five nils on dimension can never be
greater than log of
type of space
okay
one other example of a large little sun
dimension and this is going to come back
after the break so it's good to try to
understand it
this actually has this property of being
on the natural numbers i kind of like
that
but uh it's slightly different in the
sense that
it's it has two ends to the threshold
it's like an interval but not any
interval it's like intervals between
like
any integer and twice it
okay
and my claim is that this still has a
little some dimension that's infinite
the reason is that if it was fine i'm
essentially going to rule out its
finiteness by saying that it has to be
bigger than any d
as soon as you fix the d
i can choose
sort of the farthest into the line
like between two to the d and to the d
plus one
and if i just focus on what's happening
on two to the d and two to the d plus
one
sort of i actually have all possible um
thresholds now like let's ignore what's
happening outside
okay but on the inside i have all
thresholds
between two to the d and two to the d
plus one now it's natural numbers but as
you said
if i have all the thresholds then at the
very least my vc dimension sorry my
little dimension is going to be d here
so i can repeat this for any large d
i'll just pick something farther closer
to infinity
okay
and that's why the little sun dimension
of this class
is any questions about this
let me just highlight something and i'm
going to come back but i think it's
worth highlighting here
i gave you two different ways of
creating an infinite little sun dementia
one is here
that technically speaking there is no
single tree that you can grow it
infinitely long
but for any depth i tell you you can
make a fresh tree of that depth for me
because if you want to like at some
point you're going to hit the block you
cannot go deeper
but the one i gave you in the last slide
there's a single tree that you can grow
infinitely long
this turns out to be an important
distinction so i'll come back to it but
have have it in mind because i think
it's interesting
okay so now what characterizes online
learnability happens to be this little
sun dimension again both upper and lower
bound that's why we call it a
characterization and
sort of why should it lower bounds is
essentially the binary search trick i
did with you
there was nothing special about
thresholds as soon as you have this kind
of a tree
you could let the adversary pick xy
uniformly it's a path uniformly at
random
you have the same dilemma no matter what
you're going to make a mistake with some
probability a constant and there's going
to be a perfect classifier
this um
this is really good if you want to think
about infinite little sum because
there's you will never finish this tree
but actually uh if you're thinking about
finite
the trick here is that
instead of because this tree never grows
after necessarily after l after a little
some dimension depth so you keep
repeating the first thing many times and
then you repeat the second thing many
times and you make sure that you label
them at random so there is no
information from one now to the next
so this is kind of that at a high level
how you would make sure that the little
stone of
uh lives on dimension will enter your
regret this way
now
why upper bound
um
it's a really intriguing question
uh
partly because little sun trees
by construction
inductive
and because of that they actually lead
to an inductive algorithm
the easy case is say
i really did keep a perfect classifier
so i just want to know the number of
mistakes you are making
and one way to keep think about this is
that well the algorithm that should
really use some dimension
is the one that of course at every step
it rules out any hypothesis that has
ever made a mistake there's no point
keeping them around
they're not going to be the the real
answer
and then
for everything else i will take a look
at
which way if i predict
the majority cost of my prediction is
going to have the most power to or
complexity in its predictions
this is kind of abstract
this is kind of like thinking about just
majority vote
except not everybody not everybody is
getting a vote of one
instead what i want is to look and say
that if
i were to say
the label is plus one or if i were to
say the label is minus one
then i look at
um
the
set of
active hypotheses
had i made a mistake
then i want the little stone dimension
of the remaining set to be as small as
possible because every time i made a
mistake
i want to have created a significantly
easier hypothesis class to be working
with
which is kind of the dual of the saying
that i want the situation that if i was
correct to be as complex as possible
so the way you do this is by actually
measuring the littlest and dimension of
the set of your hypothesis that are
still valid
and would remain valid
given your next prediction this is uh
called the simple uh
sorry standard optimal algorithm
and uh
actually i don't know if the standard is
simple i have forgotten this but
it says
perfect this this is a
this is an existence proof
this is not a real algorithm
and so why is this hard actually um i
might have a slide about this no i don't
um
this is essentially actually um
this is like oops this is like bellman
equation okay and we already know that
those things are difficult to deal with
um so that's why this is by itself
more like a scientific type of algorithm
but there are other algorithms that are
really interesting okay
so this wraps us up we have five minutes
and since i'm short on time for today
material i'm going to just give you the
introduction to the next part
but i'll definitely make sure that
you'll get time to have your break
so the next question that you're going
to be looking at
is not about learnability at all it's
actually about the min max theorem
and
again we've seen a lot from especially
closest tutorial as well about these
topics
but
kind of the usage example here is any
zero-sum game that you have in mind like
most board or card games between two
people or competitions between two firms
and we're going to talk about sort of
equilibria between two people
so what's the setting here um
you have two players again i find that
the game matrix will continue to give us
a good picture picture
and they each have set of actions
and
they have utility functions that are
sort of in this
matrix
u1 and u2 of xy
and we are going to focus on zero some
games only for this part of the talk not
not for the future parts
and sort of the idea here is that uh
zero sum games means that uh the sum of
the two utilities is going to be zero so
my gain is your loss on the other way
around
uh i'm going to talk about loss for
player one uh as the minus of this
utility
i try to remain consistent uh but i'm
sure that at some point i might not be
whenever i use like uh the
upper like the capitals of u the upper
case
um it essentially means there's the
expectation of the same quantity
okay so we've seen many different
solution concepts
we talked about min max and maximum
values before
but just to go over them very quickly
this is a setting that you think about
each player taking a distribution over
its actions over as pure strategies or
distribution essentially the role
players taking a distribution over the
rows the column player is taking
distribution over the columns
and now we're asking hey would you have
rather gone first or second and that's a
min max versus max man
so min max is player one goes first
gets a p
and then player two is essentially
maximizing it's q
and max min is exactly the opposite
there's also the notion of nash
equilibrium
where it's very similar the idea is that
you pick the p and q and neither of you
can sort of unilaterally just change
your own part of the strategy
and improve your utility or loss
and the nice thing about zero sum games
is that we know there is a celebrated
theorem
that says that for zero sum games these
are all essentially the same so the min
max value the maximum value
and the the payoffs of the mixed nash
equilibria
for the first player are
essentially the same
under some mild assumptions
some of those assumptions um
they talk about x and y being compact um
some of them talk about
the set of distributions where x and y
being compact this doesn't come for free
especially it does not come for free
when your x and y or the game that we
were talking about
is now infinitely size so if i talk
about infinite matrices k matrices
whether or not min max theorem holds is
the question
and that's what you're going to see so
this is almost equivalent of our
learnability question
for learnability we were asking i have
these incident hypothesis classes
am i going to be able to learn them
and now for zero sum games we're going
to say that i have infinite
dimensional gain and sorry infinite
strategy spaces
am i going to be able to
i guarantee that min max theorem holds
and that's what we are going to
start talking about in the second part
so
this is a time for breaker soon okay but
i'm here if you have any questions
so let's start with one question that's
on the queue here from the online
participants so the lower bound you gave
for a little some dimension
the error
to the bomb and littlest dimension
applies to oblivious adversaries right
so the set of learnable classes are the
same whether the addresses or believers
are adaptive yes to say
so so
so maybe that's actually even a better
question
the better answer is that
for
min max type regret guarantees uh and i
know i just talked about min max in
terms of games it's the same thing
um so as in the the best uh regret
guarantee that you can give that holds
for the worst case
um oblivious and adaptive adversaries
are more or less equivalent um
maybe not not even say more or less
they're essentially equivalent
uh
we i
want to emphasize on adaptivity because
in the next part of the talk
i will start talking about a slightly
different model where adaptivity is a
significant uh both challenging aspect
and interesting aspect of the problem
but otherwise so far obliviousness and
adaptivity are essentially like they
wouldn't have changed any of the things
i talked about
and you can see i was talking about the
adversary essentially picking a path
which
is essentially like being oblivious like
ignoring the algorithm's choices
are there any other questions
well so i guess one more comments last
remark on
a means also related means comment
so the optimal algorithm is not a proper
one right that's a good question i will
talk about this uh
next time next in half an hour all right
so
okay all right so let's go get some
coffee okay see you in half an hour
um